[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we have new job numbers and
they're they're pretty ugly quite
frankly so before the start of the
corona virus pandemic the US had about a
hundred and fifty eight million people
working now you probably have heard
republicans bragging about how more
people were working before the corona
virus pandemic than ever before and
that's true but also more people were
not working before the corona virus
pandemic than ever before this is a very
popular political football that i want
to remind you of before we move on to
the data which is the u.s. population
grows so if you have roughly the same
portion of the population working and
not working at almost any point in time
you can accurately say we have more
people than ever working or you can
accurately say we have more people than
ever not working both are often true
because the population keeps getting
bigger when it's a Democratic president
the Republicans focus on the number of
people not working when it's a
Republican president they focus on the
number of people working it's a
meaningless statistic absent population
growth of sort of rates and that is
where that talking point comes from but
needless to say a hundred and fifty
eight million people were working prior
to the start of the corona virus
pandemic we now have a total of at least
twenty two point three million people
who have lost their jobs today we
learned that another five and a quarter
million people filed for unemployment
benefits last week we get the data on a
one-week delay so today we learned about
the numbers from last week this brings
the total to about 21 million people who
have filed for unemployment benefits
since the start of the corona virus
pandemic
this is thirteen percent of the working
population that have lost their jobs
the the real number is even higher and
what I mean by that is there are systems
at the state level for filing for
unemployment benefits that are over the
max they are stretched they are
overwhelmed phone systems where it's
just busy they can't even put you in the
hold queue web systems that are just
crashing because of the number of people
trying to file benefits so this is the
number of people that have been able to
file benefits you've got all the people
who have tried but failed you also have
people working in under the table jobs
who do not qualify for employment
unemployment benefits traditionally even
if exceptions have been made so that
they do in this particular case many of
them don't know it and they've simply
lost their jobs and not even filed so
the real rate is much higher now we have
a situation where the unemployment rate
as we typically see it this is called
the u3 rate it's going to be almost
useless very soon and I'll explain why
the u3 is going to go up because tens of
millions of people have lost their jobs
but it's likely to go up only a fraction
of the sort of real unemployment rate
for this reason and it's
counterintuitive you might think if 13
percent of the workforce lost its job
how is it that the unemployment rate
might only go from like 4 to 6 or 4 to
7% it doesn't make sense the way our
system works the u3 which is that rate
that is publicized though it's 3.8 it's
4.2 when you aren't looking for work you
are no longer considered unemployed from
the purposes of the unemployment rate
this has always been the case and you
know during Obama as usual as the
unemployment rate went down you had
Republicans say the system is bogus if
you stop looking for work you're no
longer considered unemployed that's been
the case for decades so again it's
another distraction technique that the
right loves to use but in this
particular very special situation there
are going to be millions of people who
have just lost their jobs who are not
looking for work because normally when
you file for benefits you have a
questionnaire to fill out or you might
be doing it online you might be
answering it on the phone and you are
asked are you looking for work have you
interviewed anywhere for work give us a
list of where you have
you need to do that in order to get
benefits if you don't say that you're
doing that you don't get the benefits
because so many of the current job
losses are pandemic related job losses
that is not required you are not
required to be looking for work you're
only required to be keeping in touch
with your employer so this could create
a very confusing situation where despite
22 million people 21 million people
losing their jobs we may only see a
couple point uptick in the official
unemployment rate because that's the way
the unemployment rate is calculated
Republicans would complain about this
during Obama's term they'd say the
economy is much worse than the rate
tells you because all these people are
so sick of looking for work in this
terrible Obama economy which wasn't true
that they've stopped looking and so
really the the the u3 is inaccurate
Leeloo
that's true but that's always the case
here this really matters because you are
not required to be looking for work to
receive unemployment benefits and then
there's the issue of the real number is
way higher over whelmed unemployment
systems as I mentioned people trying to
file claims but unable to people who
have lost jobs where they traditionally
don't get unemployment benefits so the
true number sadly is way higher than 21
million people now in real terms how
many of these 21 million jobs are going
to reappear as the pandemic starts to
fade the answer is we don't know number
one when we talk about the pandemic
fading there's not going to be one day
where we flip a switch it's going to be
a process it's a process that could take
up to 18 months in some ways shapes or
forms one report said for restaurants
for example July is going to be the
limit for a lot of restaurants at which
point many restaurant owners will just
start walking away from their leases and
not planning to reopen really really sad
because yesterday was the record death
rate a number of deaths rather in both
the United States and globally so we are
not exactly at a time where we should be
planning to reopen despite Donald Trump
announcing yesterday that today he would
give a list of states that he wants to
see reopen right away one other data
point just
out of curiosity we did a survey of our
own audience and we asked has your
income decreased due to coronavirus
almost two-thirds of our audience says
they are their income is the same or
higher during the virus 11% saw their
income decrease anywhere from 10 to 30
percent nine percent said their income
is down 40 to 70 percent three percent
said their income is down eighty to
ninety percent but 14 percent of our
viewers and listeners say their income
dropped to zero notice that 14% of our
audience has lost all their income it
looks like 13 percent of the workforce
nationally has gone on unemployment
benefits so very similar numbers numbers
tracking very similarly there so we've
got a big uphill battle to get back to
where we were industries may change
discussions of nationalizing certain
supply chains are already starting
whether it's masks or medical equipment
or whatever because of the virus
anybody pretending to know what the
economic landscape is going to look like
in 18 months is simply guessing and we
need to understand that we need to sit
with the uncertainty because we really
don't have another choice there are two
Republican Senate races for 2020 that
we've been paying very close attention
to and in both of those races Republican
incumbents are in bigger and bigger
trouble every single week and it is
delightful views it's there's so much
bad news going around right now um bad
economic news bad health news bad news
about you know the laughable nature of
American leadership global the globe the
presidency seen as a global
laughingstock around the world this is
good news I'm talking about Arizona and
Maine I'll tell you about both of them
starting with Arizona in Arizona Martha
McSally is the junior senator
she has never been elected she was
appointed to serve out the remainder of
the late Republican Senator John
McCain's seat she's horrible I mean
truly horrible she now wants to be
elected for a full term she's running
against or running against her rather is
astronaut Mark Kelly Mark Kelly is the
brother of astronaut scott Kelly Scott's
been a guest on this program very
interesting conversation
mark Kelly is also the husband of former
Democratic congresswoman Gabby Giffords
who was tragically shot years ago you
may remember the story and Mark Kelly
would be a tremendously good replacement
for Martha McSally and mcsalley isn't
doing well and I take great pleasure in
that in the latest poll mark Kelly is
ahead of martha mcsalley by nine points
this is huge it's hugely important for
the 20/20 balance of Senate power which
we've been talking about because if
Democrats are going to take over control
of the Senate in November and it's a
very uphill battle winning this seat
back is essentially a necessity then we
go to the state of Maine in Maine we
have our old friend the perennial II
disappointed Republican senator Susan
Collins she has a serious opponent and
that opponent is Democrat Sarah
Gideon Susan Collins was first elected
in 1996 she's had pretty easy
re-election every six years in 2002 in
2008 and in 2014 and she is sort of
known for this is not a great thing to
be known for but she's known for acting
like she might take a stand against her
own party against the Republican Party
but then in the end she always falls in
line you might remember that she was
very disappointed with Brett Kavanaugh
but then voted to confirm him to the
Supreme Court she was very disappointed
with Donald Trump's actions with Ukraine
but voted to acquit him in Trump's
impeachment trial months ago even though
it feels like that was years ago
so it is very much long overdue for
Susan Collins to go bye-bye
Sarah Gideon is trying the latest poll
is old now it's from March but it has
Gideon four points ahead very tight but
heading into her last reelection Susan
Collins had pretty high approval ratings
as high as 69% in 2014 Susan Collins
latest approval rating is 37 percent
okay
Susan Collins was reelected in 2014 with
a 69 percent approval rating her
approval rating is now 39 percent this
is very bad news for Susan Collins it's
very good news for Sarah Gideon but
both of these races races are going to
be fight so we can't take anything for
granted the reason I'm telling you this
is not so we can all sit back and say
hey we've got two of these that were
going to take over why I'm telling you
this is to get you involved as you think
about phone banking if we remain stuck
at home for the foreseeable future these
are two great races where you could get
involved now I know some of you are
going to write to me and you're going to
say David you centrist chill
neither Sarah Gideon nor Mark Kelly are
uber progressive Bernie Sanders types
that's true but we're talking about
removing some really toxic Republicans
here we should all be fighting hard for
that neither Mark Kelly nor Sarah Gideon
are as left as Bernie Sanders but they
are orders of magnitude better than what
we have there right now and it's going
to be either mcsalley or Kelly right
that's it it's either going to be Susan
Collins or Sarah Gideon those are the
choices and defeating these two would be
plus two for Democrats in the Senate
we're going to lose Alabama right now
former senator and former attorney
general Jeff Sessions is running against
doug jones remember doug jones won
against in a special election against a
serial accused sex assault or a predator
i don't know what word you want to apply
to him and now jeff sessions wants his
seat back jeff sessions is winning by 13
in the latest polls we will almost
certainly lose that seat so we need
these two just to get +1 the very
important consider phone banking there
we'll talk about other important races
upcoming make sure you're following me
on twitter at deep Ackman let me know
how the quarantine is going for you or
if you've unilaterally decided to end
your quarantine I would want to hear
that as well i'm deepak minh on twitter
quick break back after this the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Gregory lassen and Guido Franz
Rita Franz also want to say thanks to
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day that's Don nori who's been with
us almost five years I won't take up any
more of our precious time together today
with this other than to say grab a
membership yourself at join pakman.com
the level of discussion on the David
Pakman show reddit lately has been very
very high and I mean a lot high to quote
our president join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash reddit a user
named JP din Z's posted a very
interesting comparison of the policies
of Bernie Sanders Joe Biden and Donald
Trump to try to make clear that there is
really not very much in common between
Biden and Trump and quite a bit in
common between Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders and I think it's important for
us to understand I mean listen I don't
think it's useful to pretend that Joe
Biden is something he isn't and that
applies to both sides Joe Biden is not
Bernie Sanders Joe Biden is not a
progressive Joe Biden is not going to
push for nearly every policy that Bernie
Sanders was pushing for but Joe Biden is
way closer to Bernie than he is to
Donald Trump and whether you look at the
minimum wage paid family leave Citizens
United
the death penalty prison sentencing
related to drugs abortion rights capital
gains taxes wealth taxes the climate
nuclear power you actually see that
Bernie and Trump are both knows sort of
and Biden is a yes so in any case that's
not bragging about Biden's position but
the point is if we say Biden's more like
Trump than Bernie we are just very very
wrong
I want people deciding on the facts if
you think that we are better off with
Trump than Biden then vote that way but
don't beat
tricked into making a move that helps
Trump because you incorrectly believe
that Biden and Trump share significant
policy when really the the vast majority
of the shared policy is between Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders two different
degrees on many issues decide however
you want but I want you to decide with
the facts not with incorrect talking
points so a very good post by JP din zis
el bonza no posted is David overusing
the word weaponized and a lot of people
in the responses saying this seems like
a weird thing to be concerned about and
it's an appropriate word to be using
yeah my my use of the word weaponized
has definitely increased lately because
we're seeing so much weaponization by
the government Donald Trump has weapon
weaponized disinformation
Donald Trump has weaponized his
delusions of grandeur Donald Trump has
weaponized his own and his followers
ignorant and gullibility we are seeing a
level of weaponization both by Donald
Trump and by right-wing media that
carries water for him that is like
nothing I've ever seen and I was
actually watching I went on YouTube and
I found some clips of fox news covering
george w bush's presidency and of course
you know it's the normal playbook how do
you support a standard republican
president if you are standard right-wing
media and it almost seemed quaint
compared to the degree of weaponization
that we are seeing today it's not a
defense of george w bush and it's not a
defense of Fox News it is merely a
shocking realization I came to of how
far things have slid since the george w
bush fox news era to the trump fox news
o a n phase in which we now find
ourselves
lastly user turkey bacon and cheese
posted to the reddit pedro call
appreciation writing i just want to say
that the pedro part of the show was
hilarious a nice change in mood and
worth the time he wasted banks for the
laugh yeah i actually i got an email
from someone claiming to be pedro over
the weekend
with what they claimed was a picture of
them and it was just a drawing of a
completely stereotypical Mexican man and
it struck me as incredibly offensive to
some degree and also hilarious because
Pedro claims to be Colombian but the
drawing was of what you would see as a
stereotypical Mexican like mariachi guy
it's crazy the entire Pedro arc is
taking on a life of its own but I'm glad
people are getting some enjoyment out of
it in these otherwise very dark times
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it ok you are not going to
hear me say at any point during the next
six and a half months which is the
lead-up to the November presidential
election you are not going to hear me
say Joe Biden's got this I'm just not
going to do it for two reasons number
one I actually believe it's going to be
a fight to the end and I think there's a
very good chance Donald Trump ends up
getting himself reelected but I'm also
not going to say it because I don't want
to risk a single person hearing me say
something like that and deciding that
Joe doesn't need their vote and they can
stay home or vote third party or
whatever the case may be there is a path
to Trump's reelection that includes the
effects of coronavirus on Democratic
turnout combined with Trump successfully
using the virus to bamboozle and goad
his base into thinking he did a great
job with the virus plus Trump doing just
enough to keep the stock market
buoyed I think is the term I would use
so that it kind of looks like the
economy is okay even though it's
imploding but I also am NOT going to
hide the polling from you so that's why
I want to talk today we have national
polls that look good for Biden we have
state polls that look very very mixed
for Joe Biden so let's look at some
examples starting with the general
election in the general election
hypothetical polls Joe Biden is
currently winning by an average of 5.5
points now this ranges in a tie on Fox
News in Fox News's latest poll all the
way up to Biden leading by 11 in a
recent CNN poll
and everything in between and the
average is that Biden is up 5.5 now
let's think about 2016 in 2016
the national polling average going into
the election was Hillary up three point
three and Hillary ended up winning
nationally by two point one so the polls
were closed they were off by about a
point in terms of the national popular
vote of course we have an electoral
college system and despite losing the
popular vote badly Donald Trump won the
electoral college now currently Joe
Biden at five point five points ahead
has a much bigger lead then Hillary
Clinton did going into the 2020 election
but remember the electoral college
system still would allow Donald Trump to
win even if he lost the popular vote by
you know five and a half points would be
a stretch but if Biden wins the popular
vote by four it's still very possible
that Donald Trump could win the
electoral college it would be tough but
it would be doable so now let's look at
some individual states North Carolina is
not looking great for Joe Biden there's
a recent North Carolina poll where Trump
is seven points ahead of Joe Biden back
in 2016 Trump won North Carolina by only
three if Trump doubles his margin of
victory in North Carolina from 2016 to
2020 it's a signal of very bad things
for Joe Biden but then we've got some
places where it's looking very bad for
Donald Trump Arizona is one example we
talked earlier in the show how
Republican incumbent senator Martha
McSally is losing by nine to Democratic
Senate challenger Mark Kelly well Joe
Biden is winning by an average of four
point four and as button by as much as
nine in one poll in Arizona that's a
state Trump won in 2016 if Arizona goes
from Trump winning by four to buyed and
winning by four that's an eight point
swing and it's very very bad for Donald
Trump
Virginia is another example right now in
Virginia
Biden's winning by an average of seven
and by as much as ten in the latest poll
Hillary only won by five in 2016 so
again if Virginia goes from Hillary plus
five to Biden plus seven eight or nine
or even ten that is very bad for
so what's the take away the take away is
no matter what the polls say go and vote
ask for an absentee ballot if that's
what your state is doing do not sit this
one out because it is likely to be a
huge fight I was talking over the
weekend on zoom' with a few friends who
are very much journalists writers et
cetera many of them feel that November
is going to be a blowout they just don't
know who's gonna win
the idea being it won't be close either
Biden will very much pull away with it
or Trump will very much pull away with
it based on what's going on with
coronavirus and the economy if that's
the case then we're gonna have to fight
very very hard for it to be Biden the
for Biden to be the one who pulls away
of course predictions are often wrong
and it may well be close and it may come
down to just a couple of states so it
will be a huge fight anything that makes
you think we've got this is very
dangerous thinking and I would encourage
you to disabuse yourself of those
notions do not get confident they have
every trick up their sleeve and with the
wild card of coronavirus and people
possibly staying home to avoid the virus
anything can happen anything can happen
last thought after seeing Donald Trump
this week talk about how he has absolute
power he can tell governors what to do
he can demand and enforce that
businesses be reopened after seeing
Trump's authoritarian slide this week I
am increasingly skeptical that Trump
would leave peacefully if he loses to
Biden now I want to be really careful
I'm not saying Trump would succeed in
not leaving if Biden wins I just mean it
won't be peaceful in that Trump will
claim it was rigged he will claim it was
stolen he will claim Joe Biden didn't
really win he may even try to start some
kind of legal challenges I do believe he
will leave but I am increasingly
skeptical that Trump will leave what I
would describe in a peaceful manner I do
believe he ultimately will leave let me
know what you think about that we're
gonna continue coverage of this issue
and others on the David Pakman show
Instagram page that's at David Pakman
show follow me at David Pakman on in
- gram later today I am going to phase
two of my 2020 open garden garden I will
be tracking and reporting all of it on
my Instagram account at David Pakman a
nice rake of levity from the coronavirus
Fiasco the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to welcome to the
program today Louis Raven Wallace author
and creator of the view from somewhere a
book and podcast about the myth of
objectivity in journalism also
co-founder of press on southern media
collective thanks for your time during
during these strange times I guess I
would say hey yeah of course so to begin
with I will sometimes get these
beautiful emails from people in my
audience who say David I love that you
are not biased in your reporting and
while I will gladly accept any
compliment it concerns me a little bit
from a media literacy perspective
because I do an opinion program I am NOT
doing reporting I'm doing commentary and
the program is very much biased in the
sense that it is my opinion in my
opinion is certainly partisan so can you
start to talk about some of the
categorization of media that needs to be
done and that maybe not everybody is
doing as well as they should
yeah that's such a cool and weird
anecdote that really sounds familiar to
me in that I think there's been this
sort of bending of the concept of media
bias over time to the point that you
know a lot of us think that bias media
is just anything we don't like right or
don't agree with or that doesn't like
vibe with us yes yeah and so I you know
a part of my sort of thesis has been
to just get rid of this idea that media
bias itself is the problem and accept
that all media in some way is biased
right we have a frame we have an
ideology we have a not you know not
necessarily a partisan political stance
but often that - that we're bringing to
anything that we produce as as
journalists and so it's less about
trying to be unbiased and more about
doing a really rigorous investigation of
what our own biases and perspectives are
and being transparent about those and so
it sounds like you know the audience
members you're hearing from they trust
you yes and they might trust you in part
because of that transparency and so
overall that that's a good thing but I
think an important sort of shift for us
right now is to to move away from this
conflation of objectivity or non
partisanship or being non biased with
being trustworthy because they are not
inherently the same and I think those
concepts have become really muddled in a
way that's actually really damaging can
you talk a little bit about objectivity
versus neutrality which is sometimes a
source of confusion and the way I've
talked about it is I could be neutral on
the issue of whether vaccines cause
autism or I could be objective which is
to transparently tell you that all the
science tells us that they don't and
that that's the the way I try to explain
it but there's probably a better
umbrella way to talk about that
difference yeah sure so you know I am I
am anti objectivity and neutrality but I
think that there is again a way in which
those concepts have been conflated over
time where objectivity might be narrowly
understood as sort of what you're
talking about
you know rigorous kind of scientific
approach to analyzing the
in an honest attempt to reflect the
closest version of truth that we can
come up with right and but more broadly
it's often been interpreted to also mean
that the reporter or the outlet is
neutral on the issue or in some way
impartial on the issue or stands outside
of it in some way and that's been sort
of the journalism school interpretation
of objectivity as well for a long time
is that it's a reflection of neutrality
for me I think even just the the idea
that there is one objective truth does
kind of fall apart you know
philosophically at a certain point and
leaves us stuck with some of the same
issues that neutrality does of like how
can we ever fully stand outside of
something and look at it objectively and
I don't think that that's possible but I
do think that rigour transparency being
meticulous being you know striving for
some version of the truth is something
that journalists can and should still
embrace in that that we do need to
separate that out from some sort of
performance of neutrality of performance
of impartiality that has been demanded
of many journalists
yeah the performative nature of
neutrality is an interesting way to put
it and I think maybe to think about that
a little bit one can visualize the sort
of corporate legacy media segments about
for example climate change where you
have two guests one of two meaning 50%
represents the scientific view one of
250 percent represents some other view
right China created it it's a hoax or
whatever that is up to me that's
performative neutrality in the sense
that it's 50/50 in this very basic sense
but it does not reflect anything about
what's actually happening out there in
the scientific or factual community
why has corporate media decided to do
that is it as simple as avoiding
criticism more from one political side
than the other or is there more to it
so yes avoiding criticism is one piece
you know I've heard people say that
journalists for all that we are willing
to go after other people are some of the
most thin-skinned folks around which is
neither here nor there to me but but I
think there are our larger forces at
play that has always been true in this
sort of performance of objectivity and
neutrality that it originated with a
business model based on advertising so
advertisers wanted to appeal to the
largest possible sort of general
audience but also often an audience that
has money that has resources right so
that might have also translated or still
translate to mean white upper-middle
class audience and so sort of striking a
balance of perform neutrality or
performed impartiality that hits right
at the middle of that target audience is
a priority for advertisers and
underwriters and sponsors that certainly
you know TV news has taken extremely
extremely seriously this performance but
I also wouldn't underestimate you know
it's not pure economic forces there are
also political forces in particular on
the right that have worked very hard for
going on five decades now to sort of
frame the concept of balance in terms of
left right and then delineate a
right-wing perspective that is actually
very very extreme as something normal
and normative and demand that that
perspective be represented and quote
unquote balanced media so the example
that you gave about climate change
climate deniers are this tiny tiny
minority right certainly in the
scientific community but also are a
minority in the general populace in the
United States and so the demand that
they always be represented in a
conversation about climate change is a
huge win for the sort of corporate
right-wing media machine that has pushed
to make that happen and you know this
sort of performance of objectivity
performance of balance and the demand of
that is
Oh dangerous in the hands of demagogues
and that's what we're dealing with now
right is journalists sitting around
talking about whether or not to say that
Donald Trump is lying because it might
be perceived as partisan to say that he
has lied when he has lied and you know
what could be more toxic to the cause of
truth than that interpretation or that
performance of objectivity and to have
journalists and mainstream newsrooms
sitting around having that conversation
which they are is such a huge win for
far-right activists who want that to be
the debate rather than the truth to be
told and then we debate the real issues
from there yeah as a very brief aside
there's a great book which may not even
be in print anymore called waves of
rancor which describes a lot of the
backstory on how that was built up
initially but so you mentioned that this
question of do we say that Donald Trump
is lying or do we not recently we've
seen CNN doing some sort of live
fact-checking
graphically with with notes at the
bottom of the screen during the
coronavirus press briefings can you talk
a little bit about the effect that the
mainstreaming of the term fake news as
sort of as a cudgel has had on
journalism and media yeah sure so you
know the mainstreaming of the term fake
news and Donald Trump's sort of use of
it as you said as a as a cudgel has been
a powerful tool for advancing this sort
of warping of the debate and and this
demand that every discussion be balanced
with with both far-right ideology or in
some cases now just Donald Trump's ideas
whatever they may be but that also that
is part of a long-standing tradition
right in the in the United States that
has always been tied up with racism and
white supremacy and so the example that
I give in my book is this idea of the
lost cause in the Civil War and
you know the Civil War was at least in
part about ending slavery and slavery
was a terror on the people who were
enslaved you know and I I'm sure I don't
need to tell you that but almost
immediately after the end of the Civil
War this sort of news story was written
about who these white Southerners were
who were fighting for the Confederacy
and what they were about and that they
weren't about slavery or enslavement at
all but you know they just wanted states
rights and their lost war was this lost
cause of states rights that had nothing
to do with racism and and in the late
1800s and early 1900s activists for this
sort of lost cause narrative demanded
balance in textbooks right and demanded
that schools in favor of not of being
less bias actually teach this story that
you know slavery had been this sort of
benign thing and that it wasn't really
what civil war was about and these nice
white people just wanted their states
rights and you know and they were nice
to the black people anyway and all this
kind of BS right but that's like the
original fake news like this sort of you
know it's lost cause and it's biased to
teach it as something that was actually
about racism and so that strategy has
been in use by racist demagogues in the
United States since forever and that's
just one example of it
Donald Trump is part of a long tradition
and you know unfortunately has amassed a
great deal of power but he's not the
first racist demagogue to amass a lot of
power
certainly not early on so in the limited
time we have left I would love to hear
from you what do you see as the lowest
hanging fruit of if we could start
teaching media literacy in seventh grade
which I think would be a great time to
start teaching it three things I think
would be really useful would be teaching
number one understand the primary
purpose of a news source which would
very quickly get you to well if the
primary purpose is to make money that
needs to be included in my analysis
number two understanding whether you're
looking at a primary source or not and
the number three distinguishing between
opinion journalism and news journalism
though that's like just an example and
there could be many other examples what
do you see
if you get a classroom of 12 year olds
in front of you as the low
hanging fruit that would do the most
good as far as media literacy goes
those are great I love your three points
I think that my big takeaway not just
for children but for adults and this is
great if we can start em young
is just curiosity right that there's
always another question there's always
follow-up so I think we end up being fed
this perception that what you read in
the news or what you hear on the news is
sort of that's it
that's the final story and the the myth
of objectivity feeds into that there are
these objective people out there who are
journalists who just bring you the story
and that's everything that you might
need to know and either you trust them
or you don't but I think all of us right
now really need to be working our muscle
of curiosity and of always asking more
questions and investigating further into
things and essentially sort of become
journalists in a way ourselves certainly
the crisis of kovin 19 and the pandemic
it's been an opportunity for that people
are seeing in real time how journalistic
fact and truth actually isn't set in
stone it changes pretty quickly in an
environment where even scientists don't
know what this virus is right and so all
of our ability to be curious and
open-minded and to actually change the
way that we think about something based
on new information and ask new questions
over time to me that's sort of the core
for both people taking in media and for
people producing it is that we we can
all embody more of that curious
journalist or curious scientist and that
a scientist or a journalist the point of
that person is not that they have the
best answers but that they have the best
questions and I think that's often
misunderstood and process is important
right understanding that because
something that was said about the virus
six weeks ago ended up not being true
doesn't mean someone was necessarily
lying it could mean that but we are sort
of iterating science is an iterative
process so is journalism and
understanding that because that's also
weaponized sometimes to say hey the
thing they told us six weeks ago was
wrong therefore
Bill Gates is trying to you know
a vaccine to sterilize people or
whatever it's all on the table because
something has was corrected the process
part seems so important
yeah and understanding that process of
investigation and inquisitiveness and I
think that's one of the most important
things that we could be teaching in
terms of media literacy is that that's
all that news is right is the best
attempt at providing facts and
information of a group of people who
brought it to you today we've been
speaking with Lois Raven Wallace author
and creator of the view from somewhere a
book and podcast about the myth of
objectivity in journalism so great
having you on I really appreciate your
time
thank you for having me the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I'm pretty cynical by nature but the
last two months of seeing how I don't
know if it's 30 percent or 40 percent of
the country has been dealing with
coronavirus it's really made me lose
like even more faith in humanity than I
had already lost at least American
humanity we already did a story on the
bonus show about how one-third of the
country believes coronavirus was created
deliberately rather than evolving as
viruses do and this is already very very
bad and we increasingly now have the
sort of Liberty crowd the people that
fetishize a myopic version of what
freedom is starting to protests that we
must open the country many of them have
even been gathering in large groups in
order to demand that the country be
opened and one such rally happened in
Michigan yesterday another one happening
I believe today in Kentucky possibly but
all of today's videos are from yesterday
in Michigan and Michigan's having a real
problem with coronavirus Michigan is in
the top eight states in cases per capita
a Michigan is in the top four states in
deaths per capita and they're not doing
that much testing they're only testing a
30 second per capita in the United
States and of course many states simply
do not have tests it's beyond many
states to be able to do more testing the
point is high death per capita low
testing per capita in Michigan people
have to stay the hell home so here are
protesters gathering in huge groups now
you're going to hear if you're not
watching I'll tell you some of what
you're going to hear now you're going to
hear screams of lock her up referring to
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
you're going to hear screams of recall
Whitmer you'll hear USA USA chants and
of course what you will see if you're
watching is a huge crowd of people when
we're trying to fight a virus that
spreads through droplet contagion take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here are interviews with two people one
guy crying about being unable to get
lawn fertilizer and a woman complaining
about not being able to dye her gray
roots bending down to show how the roots
are tragically coming in I can't go
between those houses you can't buy paint
you can't fight a law you can't pay lawn
fertilizer or grass seed or whatever
come on all statewide really you know
it's time for our state to be opened up
we're tired of not being able to buy the
things that we need go to the
hairdresser's get our hair done so I
mean listen the guy who's crying about
fertilizer if you're that desperate for
some manure just watch Trump's daily
press briefings and you'll get more more
than your daily allotment but this is
really really crazy first of all you
know the woman with the hair died 2,500
people died in the United States on on
Wednesday this week from coronavirus
this is the most in one day in any
country since the start of the pandemic
she's complaining about dyeing her hair
is the reason that the state needs to
reopen it also seems like these people
aren't just either aware or telling the
truth about what's going on in their
states because the guy law you know
crying about manure I looked into it
hardware stores are open in Michigan
they will give you fertilizer they'll
even bring you have to call ahead and
give your credit cards they'll bring it
out to your car you can order it from
Amazon Amazon shipments are taking quite
a while right now but it'll get to you
the idea that you know he's crying
because he can't get fertilizer you can
get fertilizer I don't know if he has
access to the Internet so this is the
epitome of the ugly side of America and
it is not lost on me that both of these
individuals appear to be in high-risk
groups based on their age groups that
should really be staying home right now
completely entitled completely lacking
an understanding of basic science and
they are indignant at others looking to
help people and stay home they're also
wrong on the facts and confused about
the world around them so it's sort of
like a perfect rumpus and I've said it
before I don't want anyone to
died from this but if they were only
putting themselves at risk I would say
okay you know what
if people want to risk death and they're
not endangering anyone else let them do
it like how much are we going to fight
them if they're only putting themselves
at risk let it rip so to speak but they
do put others at risk people who do
understand what's going on
recognize that those people are putting
at risk people in a position where they
may get the virus and die their actions
don't only affect themselves they affect
everybody around them so we have to act
collectively here to keep people safe
they will never change their minds until
they and their loved ones get sick and
by then it's going to be told too late
they'll have spread it already
most will still vote for Trump in
November regardless remember when Trump
said his Vietnam was avoiding STDs
during like the 1980s or something like
that for these people not dyeing their
hair as a sacrifice as tens of thousands
of people are dying in health care
workers are in warlike conditions every
day they are considering this a big
battle for them and I get it you know I
I'm sick of being home I want to see
people I want to go out I just want to
sit in a restaurant for a couple of
hours I totally understand it but this
is bigger than any one of us and
particularly for a lot of these folks
who are religious and tend to subscribe
to the idea that there's something
bigger than them that connects to their
actions every single day how is it that
they don't get that same idea applies in
a real way to what we're doing here in
trying to stop the spread it's
disheartening it's concerning it's
disappointing and unfortunately they're
not only putting themselves at risk if
it were only risking their own lives at
certain point I would say go ahead and
do it but that's not the situation let's
talk about vaccinations a little bit
we're going to cover vaccinations in
more detail on an upcoming program as it
relates to the virus but today I want to
talk about two prominent from pused
sycophants who have announced that they
will not accept any Hirono virus vaccine
that is associated in any way with Bill
Gates now for me this
entire narrative about you know the
bulette benevolent billionaires versus
the evil billionaires it's a pretty
silly one my I apply a more structural
understanding to this issue of
billionaires and the sociology and the
economics of billionaires I believe most
billionaires as people are pretty good
people but there are systemic components
in our society that favor the very rich
which often lead to unproductive
self-centered behavior on the part of
billionaires and huge corporations so
you know during the Bernie campaign
there was a lot of discussion about why
does this candidate or that candidate
hate billionaires and every candidate
addressed it differently but my view has
always been this is not about
billionaires as people it's about the
positioning of billionaires and policy
in a society that at a structural level
allows and encourages certain behaviors
where you see billionaires created and
that's really the crux of what we're
trying to deal with so my point is
talking about these are the good
billionaires and these are the bad
billionaires seems like a pretty fraught
experiment to me that being said when
you look at Bill Gates as an individual
versus you know Koch brothers as
individuals and you look at what Bill
Gates has funded versus the things that
Koch brothers have funded in addition I
get Koch brothers found fund medicine
and some good things as well
you look at Bill and Melinda Gates they
have lobbied other billionaires to give
away as much of their wealth as possible
Bill Gates has dedicated himself for a
very long time to funding and finding
cures and solutions to everything from
sanitation and developing nations
vaccines for pandemics etc yeah
Bill Gates doesn't want to pay a wealth
tax he's a billionaire when Elizabeth
Warren put out her wealth tax proposal
he said he scoffed at it he balked at it
right but if we had more billionaires
like Bill Gates than the Koch brothers
we would be better off all else being
equal so this gets us now to coronavirus
the Gates Foundation is funding
development research and possible
factories where seven different
coronavirus vaccines could be produced
now this is a huge waste of money in a
literal
cents and what I mean by that is in
order to have capacity to produce enough
vaccines to really distribute them to
enough people to build herd immunity you
have to take a chance on an unproven
vaccine you have to start building
infrastructure to produce unproven
vaccines there are seven promising
vaccine candidates right now for
coronavirus Bill Gates is already
funding factories to produce seven
different vaccines in all likelihood six
of those seven will not end up being the
vaccine okay that's a really good thing
that he is doing and his mere
involvement in vaccination is causing
conspiracy theory explosions a girl I
went to high school with has been
posting a lot of this stuff on her
Facebook page she's a big trumpet I had
to unfollow her Donald Trump's friends
diamond and silk are spreading the same
disinformation take a look at this
including conspiracies about Bill Gates
and population control and other such
nonsense Africa trying to vaccinate they
felt like stuff can start right there in
certain parts of that's what we don't
need to do not gonna make black people
not the guinea pig for this year I can't
be your experience or your project not
yes today bill yes the surgeon the
Surgeon General was talking to as a
matter of fact he was treated today
listen I tell us what we need to know
yeah but I always look at the underbelly
of what's going on that's intuition in
me yeah that's my intuitive yeah Clark
counterpart yes uh-huh
what do you Bob to do here right because
what you not gonna do you not gonna
start vaccinating black folk right and
we have to have a vaccination car just
to go together you're not gonna do that
and and what it does it it'll start with
us first
right see they got us with slavery they
got us with Jim Crow not about the push
this here mass vaccination and listen
kudos if you make your vaccines for
people and you want to help you
but I have a problem receiving any
vaccine from any entity especially
anybody like Bill Gates who push for
population control the same thing that
margot singer pushed for abortions
imagine comparing Jim Crow to a corona
virus vaccine again as I've said before
if people were only endangering
themselves I would be much more resigned
to a sort of Darwinism uh uh in a sense
as a sort of Darwinistic perspective
when it comes to what these people are
saying and doing but diamond and silk
have an audience and they post stuff and
people see it and it starts to spread
like a virus itself
Bill Gates population control bad for
black people don't accept any vaccine
that Bill Gates is associated with as it
is we are going to have trouble actually
getting the vaccine to everybody both
because of supply issues and because of
existing anti-vaxxer sentiment and now
this on top of it so it's much like with
the virus if you don't social distance
you're putting other people at risk if
you convince people not to get the
vaccine the risk of spread grows
exponentially and our ability to achieve
herd immunity is diminished if you don't
get vaccinated you are putting other
people at risk and as we've seen with
the measles anti-vaxxers when you
convince more people not to get a
vaccine you actually create pockets of
outbreaks which is exactly what's been
happening with measles so this is
stunningly ignorant but dangerous
ignorant in the modern United States of
2020 is unfortunately common and it's
incredibly applauded in some sick
circles Donald Trump jr. and Donald
Trump himself will often retweet
diamondden silk they've been to the
White House meeting with Trump like this
is really I know I used the term
weaponize too much so I'm not going to
use it but we are in an acute idiocracy
and the calls are coming from inside the
house so to speak scary scary stuff we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine
to david p here is a voicemail
criticizing me for a big faux pas i made
when talking about my urban garden on
stream yesterday take a listen to this
hello david i saw your show today and i
love you so you said today that you were
getting some you had your raised beds
built and you were bringing in some dirt
yes
and then you wondered if you should call
it soil dirt is what you wash off of
your hands and soil is live medium just
waiting to grow your vegetables got it
thank you yeah so i I clearly AM a beta
male gardener there I I don't pretend to
be an expert in gardening and I had when
I said that I was having dirt delivered
to grow vegetables my instinct was that
that wasn't the right term and indeed it
is not I am having a beautiful soil
delivery this weekend I'm going to plant
I'm in a much in the style of Howard
Dean we're gonna plant carrots and we're
gonna clamp peppers and we're gonna
plant tomatoes and we're going all the
way to the fall whoa with vegetables so
follow the adventure on Instagram at
David Pakman the planting starts very
soon the soil is imminently going to be
delivered and it's going to be very very
exciting and it is just something not
related to the virus which I think we
all desperately need right now don't
miss today's bonus show get instant
access to it by being a member or a
patron I'll talk to you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]